the easiest upsells in the world is that
you can sell more of what you just
offered them you can sell better of what
you just offered them you can also sell
new or different something that's
complimentary so you can sell fries with
a Coke you can sell a burger and then
add in fries or add in a Coke and then
each of those you can upsize you can
supersize them that's more and then if
you had a better version of coke you say
well do you want organic Coke just get
creative and think what else did this
person want and one of the easiest
things to do is just ask them what else
can I do to make this easier for you and
then sell that